about time that's how I felt when I saw
the news this week that the school
curriculum is to be updated primary
school children will be taught about
healthy relationships basic self-care
and online safety secondary school kids
will learn about mental health and
received the first update to sex
education in 20 years I used to believe
that school was just about preparing
people for the world of work and I now
realize it needs to be so much more
schooling is an opportunity to show our
kids so much and to develop them into
the very best versions of themselves
Damion Hines I salute these changes and
I hope that long may they continue you
know Michelle I have had a complete vote
fast I've had a complete turnaround on
this situation I'll explain why in a
moment you mentioned Damien Hinds why
don't we hear a little bit of what he
was saying he's speaking to all out
politics program on Sky News from
primary school actually should be
learning about the building blocks of
healthy positive relationships that
starts with things like being kind to
each other and taking turns but also
then understanding about the variety the
difference there is in the world looking
at how a certain other families may be
different from your own and then as you
get older talking about things like
permission and consent and what that
really means which itself is than a
building block for Winnie at a secondary
school and talking about some of the
more difficult issues and I did this
story this week on my radio show and I
know Trevor will be surprised to hear
this but I started ranting and raving
and saying this no I know it's
extraordinary and this shouldn't happen
and why should they be able to teach the
state teach my children one deed my
grandchildren age four or five and I
took a call from a young woman called
Katie who explained that in the middle
when she was a primary school suddenly
let me get this right
her mom actually left her dad and took
up with another lady and they had two
mums and what she went through with all
her school friends as a primary school
girl trying to explain and it was a
complete bolt out of the blue for what
that woman told me so to wrap up as it
has to be age-appropriate so I think
when he says but looking at how certain
other families may be different the
reality is people watching this now
their children or grandchildren will be
attending school where little kids have
two daddies or they have two mommies or
they have whatever it might be we have
to respect that so I absolutely agree
with you
with the one caveat and I don't know how
we deal with it I have enormous respect
for you if you are devout Muslim you're
devout Jewish whatever it might be for
those people it is an issue and I wonder
how we address that because they are
real problems with two mums and to death
we have to be aware of that machine at
the same time because I know that I know
religious sensitivities and and how they
might impact this but also if you're I
don't know a religious person that
doesn't believe in homosexuality or
whatever but you don't live in a bubble
your children don't live in a bubble and
we all don't religious right so most you
we talked about wanting integrated
societies so people need to understand
how other people live their lives and
have tolerance of that even if they
don't agree with it you need to be aware
and be tolerant I hear what you say and
I completely agree the kid should be
taught about relationships they should
be taught about concerns and about not
sending images of themselves but I do
worry that I think a lot of teachers who
teach that sex education believe that
all kids are at it all of the time and
so have to be taught about how to do it
and I think there's a I think there's a
an expectation on our kids for them to
have sex because they see they're taught
about in two schools they see it on the
movies to see it at home and I think we
have to accept that not all kids are
sexually ready at the same time and this
has actually been fed to them all the
time you know there's this belief that
sexual exploration is synonymous with
liberation and growing up it's not
necessarily a lot of kids aren't ready
for it at the same time and I just worry
that with all this kind of emphasis has
been put on it I agree with with all the
stuff you mentioned earlier but I just
think that that it is literally being
thrown out the moorlands in size and
what your man there and then I will you
your man there Hines was talking about a
lot of what he was talking about it's a
parent's job you know all the parents do
yeah I mean I'm running into a big
problem here I'm basically agreeing with
the last thing Carol said which isn't
what I'm not supposed to do I think many
years ago I did a thing about sex
program education what we did was in the
afternoon we put the children in the
desks in a secondary school and we've
said what would you like your parents to
tell you about and they
said things like I want to know what
this thing the safe period is you you
know wait where you can have sex with a
low with a low well exactly with a low
risk oh I know a low risk of being
impregnated and in the evening we put
the parents of these children in the
same desk and we said here's some
questions that your children want to ask
you not one parent in that whole
classroom could answer all the questions
that their children wanted answered so I
think there probably is a real role for
schools here in helping to make sure
that children don't do silly things but
what I worry about here is that
increasingly we are outsourcing
important questions to that there should
be family questions to schools and I
have - a big issue about that one is the
point that Nick made some families don't
take the view I take from John but about
homosexuality and I I'd feel
uncomfortable about that and the other
is teachers don't always get it right
here's a good example of something that
seems crazy to me
it doesn't cover about about sexual
pleasure which actually is the
safeguarding thing that if a child has
got an expectation for a sexual
relationship to be pleasurable then
they're more likely to get out of one
that they're not enjoying instead of
feeling like it's a duty that this is
something I've got to do a lot of girls
feel like it's just something they've
got to do if they want a boyfriend I
kind of understand what you're saying
but I think starting teachers starting
from the point of view oh look sex isn't
it great fun it's not really where I
want sex education to go yeah arguing
with Michelle and I agree because I do
think we it's a map we're living in a
much more complex world than say the
world I or you and I were brought up in
the online world and all sorts of things
has made it much yes I mean I remember
living in a street where basically
everybody lived with their mom and their
dad basically and the one boy who didn't
was almost not part of it because he's
because his parents are split up that's
not today and I think I I don't think
parents will explain it all I think
a very good idea that schools should do
it how you deal with as exist the people
parents who don't want that for their
kids I think you've got in the end give
way to the parents oh really so yeah so
I could take if I'm a devout Jewish
person or Muslim I can actually but well
that's what the rules as I understand it
aside that you can do this I'm certainly
your child to exist in a society that's
different to them because in the end
you've got to decide what is it who has
the responsibility for your child and in
the end the ultimate responsibly must be
yours and also practically Michelle I
mean most children in the end will take
their cues from their parents and their
families we have a society in which is
very what's the word separate it's often
not integrating in the way that it
should and one of those reasons is
religion and I think it's fundamentally
wrong at for an adult to put their
religious beliefs onto new you know born
children and families and you're growing
up these children in a bubble you're
raising these children in a bubble to
teach them what you think is right or
wrong so what you want to do is what you
want to do is to give the government
sway over those children in spite of
what their who's going to teach that
little Muslim boy look your ask your
your mission you're asking a different
question which is about how do we get
some communities who are essentially
outside the mainstream to accept what
mainstream opinion is and to work with
that you can't do that by effectively
taking taking away their responsibility
and their right to bring up their
children they're part of a happy healthy
integrated society I'm sorry but you
want to be part of a healthy family
first Michelle you need to be aware of
how other people live their lives and
this fight if you don't want to approve
of that that's your business but you
have to be aware of and tolerant of so
you want a teacher to tell
seven-year-old Ali everything that your
mum and dad are telling you about
morality is wrong you want a teacher to
be able to tell you you want Ali to be
told the homosexual
she's wrong I'm sorry I want him to be
told no I want him well no I won't have
to be told what the view of the society
as a whole maybe that's what schools
join me I don't know what Michel is
saying that not only have you got to do
that but you've got to tell him that
what his parents are telling him is
wrong what I'm saying [ __ ] when he goes
home and his parents tell him if you're
gay it's wrong which is what he's or
she's having bred into them as a child
I'm saying that actually they should be
something that's broader than that that
tells them that it's not wrong
well sometimes I you know that's my
that's where I am but you're on very
dangerous ground here you're saying
you're saying that the government can
decide but on moral questions religious
questions that certain families are just
wrong and that the government can then
tell that children of those families
your parents are to be ignored
what what's more important broad a
society or individual family life and I
would argue that to being a happy
healthy safe environment it's brought a
society this is the pledge on Sky News
I'm up after the break and I'm saying
that it's time to better check on
footballers wages see why did that
series
[Music]